how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder and
yesterday we got an
awesome treat from marvel studios we got
our first look
at the eternals and although it was
pretty brief
it was pretty awesome but along with
that we got new footage for black widow
shanghi and the legend of the ten rings
and marvel revealed some
official titles and release dates for
their upcoming projects including black
panther 2 which is now titled wakanda
forever which is a very fitting title
that i believe has some really deep
meaning behind it which i'll talk about
in just a bit they revealed the title
for captain marvel 2
now officially titled the marvels coming
out on november 11th of 2022 and they
revealed some other future
project release dates as well which
we'll talk about in a bit but i want to
talk
about black panther 2 wakanda forever
because i know a lot of people have a
lot of questions of what is happening
and also very recently lupita nyong'o
who plays nakia has opened up about how
the film is going to deal with the loss
of chadwick boseman so i'll break down
the new title reveal
what it means and what to expect from
black panther 2 and then i'll talk about
some of the other projects at the end
also i'm giving away a marvel legend
storm breaker to enter the giveaway all
you have to do is subscribe to me and
subscribe to cosmic culture and leave a
comment on recent videos
details in the description down below so
black panther 2
is officially titled wakanda forever and
i think this
is a great title and i think this title
is very specifically chosen for the
circumstances of what happened with
chadwick and his legacy
everyone forever is going to remember
him as black panther he
is the black panther and i'm sure
somebody else
eventually at some point in time will
come along and take on that mantle but
sorry to that person everyone will still
see chadwick as
the black panther and it's going to be
that way for a pretty long time
as kevin feige said his portrayal of the
character was
iconic but the title revealed today this
specific title means that marvel studios
is moving forward
with black panther 2 in a very specific
way
especially since they decided to not
recast black panther t'challa
just listen to what kevin feige had to
say about black panther 2 during the
investor day
i wanted to acknowledge the devastating
loss of a dear friend and member of the
marvel studios family
chadwick boseman was an immensely
talented actor and an inspirational
individual
who affected all of our lives
professionally and personally
his portrayal of t'challa the black
panther is iconic and transcends any
iteration of the character in any other
medium from marvel's past
and it's for that reason that we will
not recast the character
however to honor the legacy the chad
helped us build through his portrayal of
the king of wakanda
we want to continue to explore the world
of wakanda
and all of the rich and varied
characters introduced in the first film
writer director ryan coogler is hard at
work on the sequel now
and we'll bring the film to you in
theaters july 8th 2022.
so they're not going to recast for black
panther 2 but they
are going to explore other characters
that have been introduced in the first
film
now i do think that the title means that
we're going to explore the death of
black panther in the movie if
even just for a brief moment his death
is definitely not something that is
going to happen on screen but
in the universe they will acknowledge
his death and perhaps even give us a
funeral
marvel has done an excellent job at
paying tribute to chadwick boseman as it
is already i would not be surprised at
all if we had a little tribute in the
beginning of black panther to wakanda
forever
and it's already been confirmed that the
studio isn't thinking about using cgi
to have him in any scene so there are
two options
since they're not recasting the two
options are to address his death or have
him go
off screen on a mission somewhere for a
long time and it makes a lot more sense
to acknowledge his death
than to have the king of wakanda out
there in the background of the mcu while
all of these events are taking place in
wakanda
plus again marvel is doing a great job
at honoring chadwick boseman so they
will most likely honor him
in the film as well and will most likely
have a funeral especially if you
consider what lupita nyong'o has said
about returning for
black panther 2. in a recent interview
with yahoo she was asked a lot of
questions about black panther 2 and she
gave some insight on how she feels about
ryan coogler's approach to black panther
2 and how the film
will deal with the loss of chadwick
boseman and in the interview she said
people will ask me are you excited to go
back
excitement isn't the word i feel like
i'm in a very pensive and meditative
state when it comes to black panther 2.
his passing is still extremely raw for
me and i can't even begin to imagine
what it will be like to step on set and
not have him there
but at the same time we have a leader in
ryan who feels very much like we do
who feels the loss in a very very real
way as well
and his idea the way which he has
reshaped the second movie is so
respectful of the loss we've all
experienced as a cast
and as a world so it feels spiritually
and emotionally correct to do this
and hopefully what i do look forward to
is getting back together and honoring
what he started with us and holding his
light through
it because he left us a lot of light
that we're still going to be bathing in
i know that for sure so obviously ryan
coogler like lupita says
has reshaped the second movie and she
says that the way he reshaped it is so
respectful of the loss they've
experienced that to me definitely seems
like there's going to be some sort of a
let's not call it funeral but a
celebration for chadwick
slash t'challa we never really did see a
funeral for t'chaka when black panther
started it was a week after he died
and by that time he had to go to warrior
falls for the incarnation
so we know that wakanda picks a new
black panther very very soon after the
death of the previous black panther so i
would expect us to see a celebration of
t'challa's life and then not too long
after get a new black panther who i
think is going to be
shuri now kevin feige did mention that
they were going to explore
other characters in wakanda who were
introduced in the first
movie and those characters are of course
shuri queen
raimonda okoye nakia everett ross
and of course umbaku now umbaku could
challenge for the throne but considering
how close him and t'challa got at the
end
working together at the end of black
panther and of course an avengers
infinity war and avengers end game they
will probably go the route of him
honoring t'challa by letting his sister
become the black panther and keep it in
the family and of course in black
panther during the incoronation the rest
of the tribes didn't enter anybody to
fight t'challa for the throne so they'll
probably yield again as well and from
there we'll jump into the main story
which has a lot of rumors and reports
right now going on about what it could
be
atlantis was heavily rumored and
reported to be a part of black panther 2
however those reports were before the
passing of chadwick boseman
ryan has obviously rewritten the script
so who knows if atlantis will still be a
part of black panther 2 wakanda forever
so based off of everything that we've
heard so far that's pretty much
what we know about wakanda forever but
marvel revealed some official titles and
release dates for a few other movies in
the same trailer as this one
captain marvel 2 officially titled the
marvels is coming out november 11th of
2022
now we know that miss marvel is going to
heavily lead into the events of captain
marvel 2. and that could be where the
marvels come from we have captain marvel
and then we have
miss marvel also wanda vision did set up
some events for
secret invasion and captain marvel 2 as
well with toyota paris's monica rambo
now in the comics monica rambo at one
point in time is
captain marvel so we could very well see
her become
a marvel as well now the other ones
they've already officially titled and or
revealed the release dates for
except for ant-man and the wasp quantum
mania is now coming out on february 17th
of 2023 that is the official release
date
and guardians of the galaxy vol 3 gets
an official release date of
may 5th 2023 and then of course they had
to end it with the fantastic four which
is a confirmed project but no release
date for it yet however
it will most likely come out late 2023
so the next few years are going to be
just ridiculously
exciting for marvel fans tons of
projects coming out
awesome new footage just showed to us
and official title reveals and release
dates for a bunch of upcoming projects
let me know which one you are most
excited for in the comments down below
don't forget to subscribe and like the
video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof
you